know that
here
hello
any instructions yes
oh yeah
do you have a EU
do you have a UC
so let's take this out
take the UN out okay
come and help us out take the UN out
just keep the micro
our world is in big trouble we still
have the coffee the mangas look at
people stranded at the airports with
Airlines canceling flights because crews
are ill
at the same time the recovery from
coffee there's been an even increasing
inequalities in the world between
develop and develop in countries and
within each country
we are still
facing a dramatic climate emergency
and I would say that the goal to limit
temperature rise to 1.5 degrees is in
intensive care
to see it lost irreversibly in the next
years to come it's absolutely essential
to reduce emissions and you are
increasing them and I'm very
appreciative of European policy to reach
carbon neutrality in 2050 and to
dramatically decrease emissions until
2030. at the same time conflicts are
multiplying and we have now the dramatic
impact of the Russian invasion in the
Ukraine that has led independently of
the suffering of the Ukrainian people to
a terrible crisis both in food in energy
and in finance
now in this context it is obvious that
no country can solve these problems
alone
we need more than ever multilateralism
but not any kind of multilateralism
because no organization can also solve
the problems of this world alone we need
a networked multilateralism
and the partnership between the EU and
the UN is a fundamental pillar of these
Networks multilateralism
the EU is the strongest Financial
supporter together with the member
states of un activities but more than
the financial support we have an
excellent in-depth cooperation from
peace and security to sustainable and
inclusive development to Human Rights
but also in addressing together the
challenges of climate change of covered
and all the other problems that we face
so it is for me an enormous pleasure to
receive Ursula Van Der Lyden and the EU
commission for this joint Retreat EU UN
in which we will make our cooperation
even deeper even stronger and even more
effective for the people we care for
thank you thank you very much Secretary
General d'antonio thank you very much
for inviting us here for this Retreat
um the College of commissioner of the
European commission and you with your
Commissioners here so I'm very much
looking forward to the discussions today
and tomorrow indeed we are in a defining
moment
we just barely recovered from covet the
pandemic when Russia started the
senseless and atrocious invasion in
Ukraine
with terrible knock on effects
um not only
for the people in Ukraine that are
horribly suffering but also with
enormous knock-on effects globally
um of this senseless War we will discuss
certainly many of the topics but I want
to refer to three of them the first is
the looming food crisis
Russia is blocking the export of grain
from Ukraine
and thus bringing hunger to millions of
people
the blockade of the Black Sea must stop
and I'm very grateful Secretary General
for your tireless work to try to create
a solution
um for the export of Ukraine grain via
the Black Sea as long as the Black Sea
is blockaded by Russia we try as
European Union to offer alternative
routes for Ukraine be it by Road be it
by a train or for example on the Danube
River
secondly we are doing our utmost to
support financially the vulnerable
countries so that they are able at least
to go through the global market for uh
for for weed purchases or grain
purchases we have allocated 620 million
euros this year for this purpose but we
also think that in the mid and long term
we should work intensively with the
vulnerable countries to bring to boost
the local food production in those
countries themselves so we are also
allocating uh funds 5 billion over the
next years into Precision farming for
example in nanotechnologies or water
management in arid areas so that these
countries are no more so dependent on
the global Food Market but are able to
produce
um the the food they need locally
the second topic we will discuss
intensively is the energy crisis also a
knock on effect of Russia's war of
aggression
the fossil fuel prices are skyrocketing
with a heavy negative impact on
livelihoods
the best answer to that is massive
investment in renewable energy renewable
energy is clean it is by now more cost
efficient than fossil fuels and it
creates Independence
but of course we have also to work
intensively to make it possible that uh
the energy prices stay at a decent level
and we have come forward with a repower
EU program 300 billion euros to make it
possible for the European Union on one
hand to diversify away from Russian
fossil fuels the second pillar is very
important it is Energy savings Energy
Efficiency and indeed the third pillar
is a massive investment in renewable
energy renewable energy will play a big
role when we will be discussing the
preparation of the cop 27 this year the
Secretary General mentioned the climate
crisis and the urgency
to fight climate change
we will certainly discuss the topic of
not only carbon pricing but also the
Just Energy transition Partnerships that
is
highly industrial industrialized
countries supporting other countries
vulnerable countries to
get out of coal and into renewable
energy we are for example having a
project with South Africa but also
leading on other projects in this Just
Energy transition Partnerships
the preparation of cop27 will be
Paramount because it is so important to
Rally the world to commit themselves to
fighting climate change we should not
um weaken the efforts because of other
crises that we have because the big
looming crisis in the background is the
climate crisis and the third topic is
indeed how we can better deliver
on the sustainable development goals
the European Union is aware of massive
investment gaps globally in the green
transition for example and therefore we
have put up global gateway an investment
program abroad 300 billion euros
to support the transition to The Greener
digital
in other regions of the world for us it
is important that this investment is
transparent and of high quality
and paying into the sustainable
development goals so many topics to
discuss together
indeed a Secretary General the Antonio
you mentioned that the European Union is
the largest financial contributor to the
United Nations and there's a good reason
for that
because we are deeply convinced that the
one and only way
to have a peaceful and prosperous
um
cooperation between countries globally
is through the rules-based order and
multilateralism and of course the core
is the United Nations as guardian of the
U.N Charter and multilateralism so it is
a very good investment contributing to
the United Nations many thanks for
having us here and I'm looking forward
to the next two days thank you very much
thank you
foreign